what's the story with you and red skull
well i don't know i mean i came across
this last week and
and someone tweeted me this this cartoon
this comic
captain america comic and
i saw this screenshot of red skull
looking at a
computer screen and it said ten rules
for life
that was one text box it said order and
chaos
and there was a couple of other boxes
and i thought well that seems to be
making a reference to my work i mean 10
rules for life is
pretty close to 12 rules for life and of
course the main themes i discuss are
order in chaos
um i mean one book is about order and
the other's about chaos and my first
book is about both so
it's a joke you know associating my
ideas with
this arch villain magic super nazi
red skull and then as i looked into it
more deeply
and as people sent me more information
it became clear that
at least some of the inspiration
for this red skull character in this
captain america
uh variant was appeared to be
targeting let's say or satirizing or
warning about
my ideas and so i've been playing with
that ever since i suppose on twitter
people are producing memes now of red
skull
oh superimposed upon the picture of him
things i've actually said instead of the
hypothetical things that the people who
don't like me wish i said and then
purposefully misinterpret
and so that's that and
it's i'm trying to make it into
something playful
it's so absurd it shocked me to begin
with i couldn't believe it
to begin with it especially when i found
out who the author of the comic book was
so you know he's uh intellectual figure
among the leftist community uh
relatively well known
and politically correct and
i i didn't expect it it it really threw
me for a loop to begin with
i mean it's really something to see
yourself portrayed
let's say parodied satirized um
as a i've been called a nazi before it's
not pleasant but
this is one step beyond that i mean
nazi apparently isn't enough i have to
be a magical super nazi
and you know by implication well really
it's so it's so
it's so surreal and absurd that that i
couldn't believe it to begin with
and it and then i think what's happening
with it is so comical
because red skull is a demonic character
i mean he's a satanic character and
in his looks and in his actions and
people are putting my words over his
representation and there's a jarring
discontinuity between the visual image
and the actual words especially for the
quotes that have been derived from my
talks that are in some sense more
straightforward and
and commonsensical like you know
clean up your room or or don't lie
um they're not exactly the sorts of
messages that the most malevolent
imaginable
nazi super villain would dream up and
promulgate so
i think we're doing a t-shirt
based on this image a kid
developed in eastern europe which is a
variant of the hail hydra logo
except it's transformed into a lobster
we're going to market a limited edition
poster and then donate all the proceeds
to charity
that's that's today's plan that should
be launched by
tomorrow so that'd be what's today's
thursday april
what is it today 11th or so
i don't even know what date it is april
8th it is
the 8th so yeah i think that'll be up on
the 9th or 10th of april
so well if i'm playing with it if that's
not turning chaos into order i don't
know what is
well it's kind of an interesting
challenge you know and and
when because i've been so ill it's been
very difficult for me to maintain my
sense of humor which is a terrible loss
um you know it's the best response to
that sort of thing is
is a deft play you know rather than
an outrage even though it it is
outrageous
it's it's outrageous to the point of
being surreal and
that's partly why it was so shocking to
me i couldn't believe that that could
possibly be
real but there was you know and
many people who fancy themselves as my
enemies
have pointed out that well i'm probably
so much like
this red skull character that i'm just
imagining that it's a parody of my ideas
but
i'm afraid that's a pretty weak argument
given the
you know virtual word for word
similarity of ten
rules for life and chaos in order
no that's not a coincidence sorry
we can just add it to the list of weird
things that's happened over the last 18
months or so that you've now ended up in
a marvel comic
yeah well it's like a weird thing seems
i i don't know
yes my life seems to predictably consist
of
unpredictably weird things and i don't
really know what to make of that
and neither my family as well because it
tends to throw them for a loop as well
although my daughter at the moment is
having some fun playing with this
she's also healthy enough to have
regained her sense of humor so
she's quite enthusiastic about the
opportunity that this
lays out